petite leçon de conduite à jaïpur depuis
qu'elle s'est installée ici il y a 6
mois
diane a appris à jouer du klaxon pour
s'imposer dans la jungle urbaine
ici il faut regarder partout parce que
ça peut arriver de n'importe où une
vache un chien ans ange
un chameau non mais vraiment si on paie
cash
voilà une moto qui te passe devant un
gars qui traverse salaires pas mon truc
or il ya un bus qui arrive donc je vais
vite médaille
il n'y a pas de priorité à droite il ya
un code de la route mais il faut pas en
tenir compte parce que si l'on tient
compte des futures on passe pas à 25 ans
cette berrichonne apprentis bijoutière
vient d'ouvrir sa propre entreprise
d'export à jaïpur ce qu'elle est venue
chercher ici ce sont des pierres
précieuses et des bijoux
c'est un peu la caverne d'ali baba à
quelques centaines de mètres de là une
autre européenne fait son marché
si j'étais hyundai s'est fait main c'est
combien
quatre mille roupies c'est de la bonne
qualité
oui mais c'est très cher elle aussi est
à jaïpur pourra faire mais gabriella
cortese
elle cherche des tissus ce jour-là elle
arpente un des bazars populaire de la
vieille ville un incroyable bric à brac
d'objets divers et parfois improbables
oh
son objectif dénicher ce qui fera la
mode de demain à paris c'est pour les
couples
au clic et que j'achète ça c'est mignon
oui ça intéresse déjà ça donne des idées
pour pouvoir développer des nouvelles
formes puis des idées de broderie pour
coudre sur les vêtements
gabriella cortese est l'une des
stylistes parisiennes les plus en vogue
du moment
ses robes d'inspiration ethnique orné de
broderies et de paillettes se retrouve
en couverture des magazines et jusque
sur les marches du festival de cannes
elle possède une quinzaine de boutiques
aux quatre coins de la planète et depuis
18 ans c'est à jaïpur qu'elle puise son
inspiration
suivez ni hadji pour la première fois
parce que il ya un savoir faire dans
l'impression artisanale qu'on trouve
nulle part au monde on a des artisans
qu'ils se transmettre ce savoir-faire de
père en fils
il ya deux cents ans leur famille
faisait la même chose donc ce qu'ils
affinent leur travail
c'est magnifique benoît nez et à jaïpur
il y a un savoir faire unique au monde
dont elle a fait sa marque de fabrique
ce sont les blocs print des tampons en
bois sculpté utilisé pour l'impression
de tissus aujourd'hui justement elle
vient vérifier dans cet atelier une
commande de foulards pour la saison
prochaine
le dessin qu'on leur a donné on attend
ses dessins se descend là du milieu qui
est en train d'être insultée là et après
c'est en bon serbe pour faire
l'impression donc c'est ça qui est
magique
[Musique]
cette technique d'impression millénaire
requiert patience et minutie
[Musique]
une précision millimétrique qui fascine
toujours gabriela
[Musique]
il a fait tous les passages de grille
l'autre a fait les passages de blanc et
lui fait les passages d'or regard comme
le tampon est petit mais c'est ça qui
est beau c'est même un peu rigolo de
voir les extrêmes d'arrivée du vraiment
fait main de l'artisanat de tout ça à à
paris et voir par exemple lui rend
bouquet porté au festival de cannes sur
les marches voilà cesser ces décalages
là je t'en prie sont géniaux je leur
avais laissé ce procès je trouvais plus
ok disent ok ce jeune là d'accord mais
pas celui ci est oui alors il faut du
jaune clair comme celui là la glisse
avec les motif qu'elle leur a donné
gabriella doit maintenant choisir les
différentes compositions de couleurs
[Musique]
ensuite il faudra 10 heures pour
fabriquer un foulard
là c'est pas fini mais on voit tout de
suite qu'on n'a plus envie de ça que de
ça par exemple
ce qui est incroyable c'est les raccords
comme ça des dessins qui ne bave pas qui
ne sont pas de simples et ce qui ne
gâche rien c'est qu'ici les coûts de
production sont dérisoires les ouvriers
gagnent entre 5 et 10 euros par jour de
manoeuvres comme ça en france serait
hors de prix serrés inabordable serait
quelque chose qui approcherait de la
passion qu ici et si on fait des
fabrications qui sont ont fait un nombre
de pièces qui est important et on fait
des fabrications qui sont devant le prix
du marché qui sont pas chers comparés à
ce que savoir faire qu'il ya ces
foulards devrait arriver dans les
boutiques parisiennes cet hiver ils
seront vendus une centaine d'euros pièce
[Musique]
jaïpur en inde
une ville créé au xviiie siècle par un
maharaja visionnaire qui voulait attirer
les artisans les plus réputés de la
région
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des sculpteurs des couturiers et surtout
des bijoutiers qui trois cents ans plus
tard font toujours la réputation de la
ville devenue une plaque tournante des
pierres précieuses dans le monde
[Musique]
endormi pendant des années la capitale
du rajasthan jaïpur attire de nouveaux
même au delà des frontières de l'inde
des touristes venus découvrir le riche
passé des maharadjahs et des superbes
marbre incrusté la des créateurs de mode
ou de bijoux
deux millions et demi de dollars à la
recherche de parures d'exception sur
deux jeunes entrepreneurs venus se
risquer au négoce des pierres précieuses
c'est pas une pierre naturelle c'est
synthétique la colle ou encore des
hommes d'affaires qui dépensent des
millions d'euros pour rénover des palais
gigantesque jamais s'énerver ici pour
toujours prendre les choses avec
beaucoup de philosophie beaucoup de
calme
je me suis aperçu que chaque fois qu'on
se mettait en colère ça n'arrangeait pas
les choses mais à côté de ces nouveaux
seigneurs de jaïpur la misère s'impose à
chaque coin de rue alors que certains
doivent travailler dès le plus jeune âge
d'autres livrés à eux mêmes ne peuvent
compter que sur la débrouille
[Musique]
palais royal de jaïpur les maharadjahs
de la ville s'apprête à rejoindre la
foule aujourd'hui c'est la fête des
couleurs
[Musique]
m
l'une des plus importantes fêtes
hindoues du pays
[Musique]
éléphant et fanfares sont de sortie
comme les trois millions et demi
d'habitants de la ville
[Musique]
pour cette occasion le roi son épouse et
leur gendre n'a renders singh président
toujours la fête qui marque la victoire
du bien sur le mal
c'est la cérémonie traditionnelle de
rely le peuple nous offre le respect
l'honneur aujourd'hui encore les membres
de la famille royale jouissent d'une
grande dévotion presque mystique
la tradition veut que la population leur
touche les pieds en signe de respect
nous les verrons nous continuons à les
servir comme nos ancêtres l'ont toujours
fait c'est la coutume depuis toujours et
en échange ils nous protègent
car pendant plus de cinq siècles les
maharadjahs étaient les seigneurs du
pays à la tête d'états princier il
possédait les terres prélever les impôts
et se sont ainsi constituer d'immenses
fortunes
c'est d'ailleurs à un maharaja qui a
fondé la ville de jaïpur au xviiie
siècle
zhai sing 2 un souverain éclairé qui en
a fait une ville prospère
une époque dont l'actuel princesse de
jaïpur l'héritière directe de cette
dynastie conserve une certaine nostalgie
ça c'est mon grand père un grand joueur
de polo
il a gagné la coupe du monde c'était une
autre époque nous aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus les mêmes ressources que
vous avez tous le pays alors qu il
pouvait faire ce qu'il voulait
aujourd'hui les choses sont différentes
pour nous il faut penser à tellement
d'autres choses avant de commencer quoi
que ce soit car depuis l'indépendance de
l'inde
les privilèges des maharadjahs ont été
abolis ceux de jaïpur ne possède plus
qu'une quinzaine de palets autour de la
ville et de leur glorieux passé
il conserve un certain art de vivre
[Musique]
ce soir la famille du maharadja reçoit
le gratin de la ville dans son palais de
300 pièces sur la liste des invités
toute la noblesse du rajasthan des
ministres mais aussi des hôtes de marque
venus de l'étranger protocole et
conventions royal sont de rigueur la
princesse et sa mère prennent leur tâche
très au sérieux
maintenant les choses sont modernes il y
a tellement de modernité
les familles sont beaucoup moins liés
donc ce soir c'est une façon de se
retrouver et de conserver ses traditions
et ses coutumes
même si les chorégraphies à la bollywood
ont remplacé les danses traditionnelles
le palais retrouvent le temps d'une
soirée
ses fastes d'antan
[Musique]
un train de vie royal que la famille du
maharajah est parvenu à maintenir en
pariant sur le tourisme
[Musique]
car le rajasthan
c'est la destination à la mode en inde
l'an dernier trois millions et demi de
visiteurs sont venus découvrir ses
charmes mais aussi son exotisme
[Musique]
des touristes venus des quatre coins du
monde qui se laisse volontiers tenter
par une balade à dos d'éléphant romande
par deux
même si c'est un peu comme sur une
autoroute
[Musique]
le mali parce qu'il est très content on
vous conseille cannibale a franchi les
alpes avec à dos d'éléphant pour sa part
dit une partie de plaisir
[Musique]
comme il se doit certains profitent du
filon toutes les russes sont autorisés
pour alléger le porte monnaie du
touriste
impossible par exemple de repartir sans
sa photo souvenir
une belle promenade vous avez déjà le
foot au oui oui c'était violée comment
c'est sûrement bien c'est tout un vrai
que toi sans discussion marc chante
tricot j'ai commis une faute en soi sans
répit les quêtes sont horribles aux
jeunes horrible négociateurs pour
arrondir leurs fins de mois
les maharadja de jaipur n'ont pas misé
sur les éléphants eux sont en quelque
sorte devenu hôtelier en particulier n'a
renders legendre
la plupart de ces journées commencent
par un rituel
le polo et dès que j'ai un peu de temps
je m'entraîne je joue c'est vraiment mon
passe temps favori j'aime ça
[Musique]
une petite demi heure à faire galoper
son pur-sang dans les jardins du palais
de rares moments de détente carnard
under singh n'a pas de temps à perdre
il passe ses journées à se déplacer
d'hôtel en hôtel d'anciens palais que la
famille a réaménagé pour accueillir les
touristes
[Musique]
ce jour là il se rend à 200 kilomètres
de jaipur dans un ancien palais d'été de
maharaja c'est aujourd'hui un hôtel de
charme d'une vingtaine de chambres n'a
renders vérifie lui même la comptabilité
le maharadja est devenu businessman un
peu malgré lui vous avez payé les
salaires de janvier en espèces oui en
espèces monsieur c'est quelque chose de
nouveau pour vous businessman je sais
mais quand on veut se lancer dans les
affaires il faut apprendre pour réussir
[Applaudissements]
narain d'heure poussent parfois le
professionnalisme jusqu'à accueillir lui
même les touristes
[Musique]
après cinq heures de car ce groupe de
saint-etienne ne s'attendait pas à
pareil honneur
madame sûr que je vous présente heures
marc aznar and things qui est marié avec
les princesses 2g pour donc il vous
souhaite la bienvenue
merci merci beaucoup d'être venu ici
et bienvenue à tous j'espère que vous
allez apprécier votre séjour au
rajasthan
merci ça valait le déplacement récit
accord s'il vous plaît le vide est prêt
voilà les trois les fronts à droite à
gauche
allez-y bonnes habitudes
mon élément
[Musique]
les maharadja de jaipur sont parvenus à
conserver leur rang
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tous les
anciens seigneurs du rajasthan
certains ont fini ruiné comme l'ancien
propriétaire de ce gigantesque fort le
neemrana au début des années 80 un
français francis bach et argue le
rachète pour une bouchée de pain
12000 euros il le transforme en hôtel un
projet pharaonique
c'est presque une ville très souvent
quand on montre les photos de ça les
gens nous disent à bout et l'hôtel il
est où
je leur dis bah c'est tout ça l'hôtel
mais c'est difficile à croire parce que
c'est c'est sûr très haut niveau et ses
réparties sur 3 ha de ne pas les
construire donc c'est assez énorme
le nouveau maître des lieux prend
toujours un malin plaisir à raconter la
décadence de son prédécesseur qui ont
encore les lieux il est ici le maharadja
regardé et je vais vous montrer
l'endroit où il est pris en photo c'est
exactement là que ça a été pris le
maharajah est terminée le maharadja
étaient tous étaient très pauvres en
fait quand on a acheté le fort les
promenades chose qu'ils achètent un
frigidaire une télévision qui l'avait
même pas ça dans sa maison il aura fallu
six ans de travaux pour transformer le
fort
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui l'un des plus beaux
palaces indien cette chambre a quelque
chose à men c'est la suite française ya
jeanne d'arc par exemple la voyez la
suite coûte 200 euros la nuit un prix
élevé pour l'inde pourtant l'hôtel
affiche régulièrement complet et explore
bleus
le neemrana est même devenu une étape
incontournable sur la route de jaïpur
pour les clients du monde entier
comment ça va comment ça va comment ça
va bonjour oui bonjour très heureux à
leur retour en inde
des anciens palais transformé en hôtel
francis on a fait sa spécialité
tombé amoureux de l'inde et de ses
vieilles pierres au point de prendre la
nationalité indienne
ce nouveau seigneur au pays des rois ne
compte pas s'arrêter là
[Musique]
patata
nous nous retrouvons ce jour-là à 200 km
du neemrana il vient faire son marché
la pierre que j'ai commandé
celle là elle est prête en charge à
chameau 1 et ça me ça arrivera peu après
nous si les livraisons se font à dos de
chameau
c'est que les camions ne montrent pas
encore ici attijari c'est le dernier
projet en date de france y est sans
doute aussi l'un des plus fous
[Musique]
vois tu sais quoi les dernières
nouvelles au sujet de la route
on en est où pour l'instant aucune
nouvelle
aujourd'hui encore aucune route
goudronnée n'accède au sommet du fort
francis a dû se faire au rythme indien
on a demandé ça y est à peu près six
mois peut-être un peu moins et des cons
dès qu'on touche à l'administration les
choses sont apple dans le sable ça se
fera mais ça se fera ce qu'il faut par
exemple pour que ça se fasse c'est que
l'on fasse venir
un officiel enfin si on fait venir un
officiel alors assoira vous obtenez
lahoud en trois jours là où ils vous
font la route trois jours jour et nuit
et francis n'est pas au bout de ses
peines car le chantier envisagé est
gigantesque
cette fois il s'attaque à trois pales et
en même temps
des édifices restée inachevée depuis
1835 et qui devait former une capitale
cela fait un mois que francis ne s'est
pas rendu sur le chantier et ce jour là
quand il fait le tour du propriétaire
mauvaise surprise à l'avancé mais je
sais déjà qui est un gros problème
là ils ont fait ce mur ils ont mal
compris et ce mur était censé être tout
droit et ils l'ont fait avec un angle
donc on est obligé de le faire démolir
c'est celui là qui n'est pas construit
correctement c'est un problème mais ce
mieux elle peut le refaire jamais
s'énerver ici pour toujours prendre les
choses avec beaucoup de philosophie
beaucoup de calme
je me suis aperçu que chaque fois qu'on
se mettait en colère ça n'arrangeait pas
les choses mais c'est très rare que je
que j'élève la boit très rare
oui oui je pense qu'il faut l'être
peut-être plus qu'ailleurs mais je
trouve que les gens travaillent très
très bien contrairement à l'image qu'on
peut avoir de l'indre les gens sont pas
travailler les gens sont très
travailleurs et du reste voyez sur un
chantier comme ça les gens travaillent
là les dames elle se repose pour
l'instant ils sont derrière nous mais
sinon elle ça travaille ça travaille
bien
francis espère que les travaux seront
terminés dans trois ans selon lui le
chantier ne devrait pas coûter plus de 4
millions d'euros
[Musique]
à jaïpur un autre homme a su profiter du
passé flamboyant des maharadjahs quand
sanji sort ses clients qui viennent du
monde entier
c'est à l'arrière de sa rolls l'une de
ses nombreuses voitures de collection
racheter à des maharadjahs vous savez
beaucoup d'entre eux avaient plus de 200
voitures dans leur garage
il avait notamment une quinzaine de
rolls royce
[Musique]
cng appartient à l'une des plus riches
familles de jaïpur la famille cassely
oil ce sont les plus grands bijoutiers
de la ville depuis huit générations il
confectionne des bijoux pour la famille
royale
sanji nous ouvre les portes de sa
caverne d'ali baba
le jam balasse c'est une pièce très
intéressante
c'est une flasque de 300 ans qui est
fait tout en or 22 carats avec un
émaillage en émeraude
ça c'est une petite paille pour boire on
peut refermer la place comme ça en fait
ça s'appelle chose qui s'était fait pour
contenir un alcool très fort laissez-moi
vous montrer ça aussi c'est un jeu
d'échecs incroyable ça c'est le roi là
c'est la tour et regarder les détails il
faut des mois pour faire des pièces
comme ça encore une fois c'est de l'or
pur et tout ça ce sont des diamants
c'est typique de jeunes des joujoux de
maharajah que la famille de sang jay a
pu récupérer à l'indépendance auprès de
têtes couronnées dans le besoin
[Musique]
voilà un colis avec de gros diamant il
n'y a que des diamants des diamants plat
avec derrière un émaillage en émeraudes
ça coûterait un million de dollars ce
savoir-faire leur a permis de se tailler
une réputation internationale qui fait
la fierté de singer la sécu staff de
suède avec sa femme
là c'est la princesse diana et la
famille
aujourd'hui la bijouterie reçoit la
visite de gabriella la styliste
parisienne semoun ou l'un des frères de
saint jacques il accueille dans son
bureau pour faire la promotion de sa
marque
gabriella envisage de réaliser une pièce
spectaculaire une robe en soie brodées
de pierres et de fer et robes qui soit
une seule robe
et qu'ils soient apportées sur les
marches du festival de l'un sur le red
carpet
quelle que soit la demande des clients
les frères k si wall utilise toujours la
même technique
[Musique]
ça serait bien par exemple pour une robe
couleur cognac les bilans n'y a qu'à la
présenter leurs plus belles pièces pour
en mettre plein la vue
deux millions et demi de dollars le
bijoutier a beau insister le budget de
gabriella n'est pas sans limite
5000 euros au maximum alors elle doit se
rabattre sur des pierres de taille plus
modeste de petits diamants noirs
exactement la couleur que j'aime
magnifique c'est exactement ça très joli
à ce jour le projet de rob est toujours
à l'étude
gabriella espère qu'elle sera prête pour
le festival de cannes 2011 des demandes
extravagantes qui ne surprennent même
plus les frères quasi oil c'est une
commande pour un cheikh arabe
voilà une première ébauche du sac il m'a
commandé il y aura des diamants
d'émeraudes et des rubis des deux côtés
et bien sûr de l'or à l'intérieur il lui
faudra plusieurs centaines de pierres
pour confectionner ce sac pour les
trouvais pas besoin d'aller bien loin
l'atelier situé au dessus de la boutique
en regorge
sur les tables des kilos de rubis et
d'émeraudes brut attendent d'être
taillée pour son sac à main
senger sélectionne aujourd'hui les rubis
ce sont des rubis de très bonne qualité
je dois encore faire tailler des pierres
parce que c'est seulement une fois des
pierres qu'on paie on peut voir si les
couleurs ça semble bon là toutes les
pierres brutes sont plus ou moins de la
même qualité
ensuite vient le polissage de la pierre
c'est là qu'elle révélera sa véritable
valeur en fonction de sa couleur et de
sa transparence
vous voyez comment la pierre change
entre le brut qui ressemble à un morceau
de verre cassé et puis voilà
une fois que la pierre est polie elle
devient magnifique aussi connaître
tailler les pierres
oui il faut de l'expérience pour quatre
ans 24 buts beaucoup d'expérience
un savoir faire qui a fait la réputation
de jaïpur et qui fait toujours sa
fortune
[Musique]
un peu partout en ville on taille ont
poli on serti du plus petit rugby au
plus gros diamants des pierres qui
arrivent des mines du monde entier
d'afrique de birmanie ou encore de
colombie et parfois en quantité
impressionnant
ce jour là c'est du jamais vu
dans la zone franche en périphérie de la
ville derrière les murs de ce bâtiment
particulièrement bien gardé cinq tonnes
et demie d'émeraude attendent d'être
vendus les pierres proviennent
directement des mines de zambie
un événement exceptionnel auquel sont
conviés les grossistes et les bijoux
outils les plus renommés de la ville
comme sans danger pour les organisateurs
la vente devrait rapporter plusieurs
millions de dollars
cette couleur verte est exceptionnel les
tons sont très riches et d'une grande
profondeur
c'est une très belle pierre 2,32 g
et bien que je ne puisse pas vous donner
un prix je peux vous dire que ça vaut
plusieurs milliers d'euros le gramme
les émeraudes sont divisé en lots
l'acheteur qui propose le meilleur prix
par l'eau le remporte
san jose a trois jours pour passer en
revue les 5 tonne et demie de pierre et
faire son offre
on examine un échantillon parce qu'on
peut pas tout voir
c'est toujours un peu un pari on fait
une moyenne à partir de cet échantillon
pour donner un prix
puis on multiplie avec le poids total du
lot et ont fait une offre
vous avez un budget limité
non non non si c'est un mot que je peut
revendre après c'est bon de toute façon
où il n'y a aucun lot 1 milliard de
dollars sinon j'y réfléchirai à deux
fois
non là on parle juste de 1 voire 2 même
3 millions de dollars finalement ce hadj
et proposera 3 millions 700 mille
dollars mais ses concurrents seront plus
généreux ce jour là il ne remportera
aucun lot diane elle ne jongle pas
encore avec de telles sommes cet après
midi la jeune française apprentis
bijoutière se rend dans un endroit un
peu particulier à jaïpur
un marché aux pierres en pleine rue
située dans le quartier musulman où l'on
peut faire de bonnes affaires
tous les jours des centaines d'hommes se
retrouvent pour vendre à même le
trottoir les pierres taillées dans les
ateliers alentours
mais difficile de s'imposer quand on est
une femme occidentale
plus difficile encore d'être certain de
la qualité de ce qu'on achète 172 kara
de pierre en émeraudes et puis le monde
excusez moi madame regarder ces émeraude
elles viennent d'où le zombie zombie
c'est 100% naturel 100 % oui c'est
combien par carat ses 1000 roupies par
cas pourquoi il y en a des sondes raid
éclair pourquoi le son du cac 40
c'est la même pierre c'est la même
qu'hier diane a des doutes
la pierre on admet mme joly la taille et
bien fait
[Musique]
sûr d'avoir une bonne qualité faudrait
que je m'installe quelque part que je
vérifie à la loupe
pour l'instant elle ne se risque pas
auprès de ces vendeurs à la sauvette
elle préfère les échoppes qui ont pignon
sur rue elle cherche des grossistes qui
pourrait lui fournir des pierres pour
lancer sa propre ligne de bijoux
je voudrais avoir des améthystes de
nouvelles variétés de pierre en fait que
qui se vante sur le marché comme la
callas night la ciani temps français sa
hantise se faire piéger avec des fausses
pierres vous avez de l'eau les bois non
juste pour voir si elle est teinté de
suspense non non c'est pas tenté c'est
une pierre naturelle
le test attend des balles à ses auteurs
en fait je vérifie il a un truc très
simple c'est que si au bout de deux
minutes après je la pose sur un mouchoir
et que mon choix redevenir le sait que
lapierre aura été atteinte et pour
certaines pierres par exemple pour cette
pierre là qui s'appelle lapis lazuli ça
arrive très très très souvent après
c'est pas très sympa quoi quand sur le
client il pleut et puis bah il à son
collier puis sa dette à faire tout ça le
fait pas trop
[Musique]
271 bah oui
attendez attendez non non non
tout ça c'est du rugby étoilé donc en
fait dans cette pierre on doit voir une
étoile à six branches mais la wii donc
voit pas trop les toiles la voie celle
ci c'est pas la bonne qualité on sait
pas du tout ce que je recherche
je recherche une qualité de plus
supérieure quand je recherche pas une
qualité de base par peur de se faire
arnaquer diane n'achètera rien ici
difficile quand on est novice de faire
des affaires en inde
mais mme gabriela la styliste qui
fréquentent jaïpur depuis 18 ans a du
mal à supporter les petits désagréments
du business à l'indienne elle trouve ici
l'inspiration elle fait surtout
fabriquer 80% de ses vêtements dans des
usines comme celle là des sous traitants
compétents et bon marché mais qui pèche
parfois par manque de ponctualité
cette fois ci c'est une livraison de
chemisiers qui inquiète gabriela ce sera
livré qu'en tout ça la semaine prochaine
pas de problème
c'est sûr ça durera combien de pièces
3500 au cou j'en envoie 1500 ce week-end
et le reste
la semaine prochaine c'est sûr où les
oreilles donc la moitié ouest problème
ces sujets le fournisseur fait tout pour
la rassurer
il va même jusqu'à lui montrer la
marchandise sur le point d'être
expédiées
je vous montre les cartons regarder
quand tout sera prêt on fera une
dernière inspection et après sa part
c'est la marchandise dès l'été prochain
afin de laisser qui démarre là et qui
devrait être déjà à paris
combien de retard nos deux semaines de
retard un peu près
ouais c'est énorme parce que quand ça
arrive à paris afrique pour dispatcher
la marchandise chez tous les clients et
c'est un peu catastrophique surtout
quand on découvre après coup des défauts
de fabrication
il y a quelques semaines certains
problèmes de fermeture à glissière
alors cette fois gabriela français
précaution vous êtes sûr que la
fermeture ne cassera pas non qu'elles
descendent bien qu'elle remonte aux
problèmes parce que si c'est de mauvaise
qualité l'as rome est foutu elle va
directement à la poubelle alors de
petits soucis qui peuvent coûter cher
mais que gabriella tolère la broderies
de perles ou de paillettes à la main ne
répondent pas toujours aux exigences des
saisons du prêt-à-porter toujours avec
notre carapace d'européens des enfants
aller vite il faut aller vite puis après
on est plongé dans la ville d'ici et on
se rend compte qu'on peut pas prétendre
aussi d'aller plus vite parce que c'est
des broderies qui sont faites sur le
cuir et longue
il ya que deux personnes qui sont autour
du métier dont perd du temps dans cette
usine
les ouvriers travaillent huit heures par
jour et gagnent jusqu'à 100 euros par
mois
des conditions acceptables pour l'inde
où parfois le travail prend un tout
autre visage
à jaïpur l'industrie de la pierre repose
en fait sur un énorme non dits dans les
ateliers de polissage un ouvrier sur
trois a moins de 14 ans des enfants qui
le plus souvent donnent un coup de main
à leurs parents mais pas seulement
farhan huit ans travaille toute la
journée et parfois même la nuit
quand il ya beaucoup de pierres à polir
révélée je colle les pierres sur le
bâton en chauffant la cire
et pourquoi tu les mets dans la bouche
pour les refroidir
farhan gagne 10 euros par mois deux fois
moins qu'un adulte
une aubaine pour son patron qui depuis
40 ans a recours à cette main d'oeuvre
bon marché
j'ai fait travailler 150 enfants
apprentis certains restent deux ans ici
d'autres cinq ou six ans ça dépend leur
intelligence
ensuite ils ont leur propre atelier
en principe le travail des enfants est
interdite en inde mais les autorités
s'aventure rarement dans ce quartier
[Musique]
farhan vie dans cette cour est avec
toute sa famille sa mère ses oncles et
sa grand mère ils sont une vingtaine à
se partager quelques pièces nous vivons
tous ensemble car nous sommes pauvres et
nous avons toujours des problèmes
d'emploi nous ne trouvons pas d'argent
c'est pour ça que nous ne pouvons pas
avoir d'autres logements
si fara n'doye travailler c'est pour
faire vivre sa famille son père n'est
plus là sa mère couturière ne gagne
qu'un maigre salaire juste un peu plus
de 10 euros
elle n'a donc pas eu d'autre choix que
d'envoyer son fils polir des pierres je
voudrais bien qu'ils aillent à l'école
qu'ils s'instruisent mais c'est
impossible il faut qu'il travaille la
maison tourne avec ses revenus
un ou deux nous gagnons 20 euros par
mois s'ils ne travaillaient pas comment
gagneront nous notre vie il nous faut de
l'argent pour manger
non
pour répondre au problème il y a
quelques mois une association a implanté
une école gratuite dans le quartier près
de 100 enfants ils sont scolarisés
tous viennent de familles qui
travaillent dans la pierre
[Musique]
c'est une école à mi temps le matin les
enfants apprennent à lire et à écrire et
suivre des formations pour un jour
monter leur propre business
mais l'après midi ils travaillent encore
dans les ateliers et continue ainsi de
rapporter de l'argent à la maison
une solution intermédiaire mais pour en
arriver là
le directeur a dû convaincre un à un des
parents souvent réticents c'est la
tradition ne se dit jamais que leurs
enfants pourraient être médecin ou
ingénieur comme eux mêmes ne sont pas
éduqués ils ne pensent pas de cette
façon donc au final ils se disent que
leur enfant fera le même métier que le
travail des pierres
c'est ça la vraie éducation à jaïpur
aujourd'hui deux enfants sur trois qui
travaillent dans la pierre sont
scolarisés
mais pour le petit farhan la situation
semble compliqué ce jour là un des
responsables de l'école rend visite à sa
famille alors que nous attendons la mère
de l'enfant
le patron débarque à l'improviste
visiblement et il tient à son petit
employé il n'est pas ravi de notre
présence
l'éducateur en profite quand même pour
lui reparler de l'école nous filmons
discrètement la scène mais moi aussi je
veux que l'enfant fasse des études mais
dans sa famille personne ne travaille
alors dans ces conditions si vous
emmener les enfants à l'école
que va faire cette famille ils vont
mourir de faim au moins grâce à moi et à
mon travail
les enfants arrivent à s'en sortir et
ils gagnent bien leur vie
la famille finit par s'emmêler les oncle
de l'enfant se range aux arguments du
patron on veut envoyer l'enfant nulle pa
ça suffit maintenant nous voulons le
faire travailler
la discussion tourne court
nous sommes priés de partir cet autre
visage de jaïpur les milliers de
touristes en visite ne la perçoivent
même pas
la plupart du temps les guides les
oriente vers ce genre d'établissement
des ateliers modèle les magistrats l'ont
people micro pour contrer la pierre
ça allait mettre ses pouvoirs sur le
disque
je voulais faire et page en revanche il
y à une réalité à laquelle gérard et ses
amis n'ont pas pu échapper pendant leur
séjour
ce sont les nombreuses sollicitations
ça commence sur les sites touristiques
où la moindre photo se monnaie mais il
est d'accord mais c'est surtout dans la
rue que les mains se tendent
tu donnerais tout le monde s'y ajouter
celles des autres villes journée passée
elle était beaucoup moins touristique
finalement et
c'est pas pareil a tué au moins
d'enfants
devant les restaurants au feu rouge ou
sur les sites touristiques l'aumône se
demande à chaque coin de rue
sur les trois millions et demi
d'habitants de jaïpur plusieurs
centaines de milliers seraient sans abri
ils s'entassent en famille dans des
bidonvilles ou sur les trottoirs
il dîne s ils y vivent il y meurt pour
survivre certains ne peuvent compter que
sur la générosité des passants
no - du curry encore plus
moi je verrais tu parles apportez votre
bol entre ces mendiants c'est souvent la
loi du plus fort qui s'imposent
[Musique]
10 heures
le train en provenance de bombay entre
en gare
de l'autre côté des rails rajjou 12 ans
s'apprêtent à grimper dans les wagons
ah ben il dégage ton pied la dégage
[Applaudissements]
son business à lui ce sont les
bouteilles en plastique vide laissé par
les voyageurs
le train ne reste que quelques minutes à
pied alors il ne faut pas traîner pour
tout ramasser et sans vie tu descends
chacun qui passe c'est une source de
revenus pour rajjou
alors pas question de se faire avoir par
la concurrence
15 j'avais cette bouteille dans le sacre
en moi ces bouteilles roma c'est une
teigne ménard est scellé mienne rend les
mois un millier d'enfants graviterait
autour de la gare de tshimbulu organisés
en bandes
ils vivent de mendicité ou de la
collecte des bouteilles rajjou lui a
échoué ici par hasard à l'âge de 4 ans
je me suis perdu que j'ai loupé l'arrêt
mes parents sont descendus dans une
autre gare j'ai jamais réussi à les
retrouver
oui mais je suis resté ici longtemps ce
sont les grands de la bande qui m'ont
élevé une fois les trains passer c'est
toujours le même circuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le sac rempli les enfants se rendent
chez un revendeur sous le pont c'est un
univers parfaitement organisée il y a
même un registre sur lequel les enfants
inscrivent le nombre de bouteilles
ramasser 19 aujourd'hui rajjou et ses
copains ont ainsi gagné 20 roupies soit
35 centimes d'euro un salaire dérisoire
mais ils tiennent absolument à nous
offrir le thé c'est un geste de
politesse en inde
pour rajjou c'est aussi une question de
fierté pourquoi tu nous offre le thé
vous êtes mes hôtes
on aurait même dû vous inviter à manger
un univers avec ses codes et tous les
coups sont permis
un monde à part que cette femme connaît
bien
latta dirige une association qui vient
en aide à ces enfants livrés à eux mêmes
très jolie les bouteilles tous les jours
elle parcourt le secteur et elle doit
souvent régler des conflits entre les
enfants
ce matin là c'est un cas grave qu'elle
va découvrir
ce petit garçon complètement hagard
vient d'être victime d'un adolescent un
caïd de la gare qui l'a droguée pour
l'obliger à mendier d'autres enfants
viennent de me prévenir
ce matin un grand lui a fait boire de
l'alcool et du pepsi avec des comprimés
de drogue pour lui permettre de
retrouver ses esprits et pour le
soustraire à l'influencé du caïd l'ata
décide de ramener le petit garçon dans
le centre qu'elle a ouvert juste à côté
de la gare
ici tous les après midi les jeunes
peuvent redevenir des enfants pendant
quelques heures
pendant ce temps là avec rajjou l'ata
décide de retrouver le coupable
tu sais dans quel coin on a l'habitude
de traîner
il est près de l'arbre c'est ça oui il
est là
car qu'est ce que tu as fait ces
derniers jours avec les enfants mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait quoi tu munich
je vais te dire tu fais monde y est les
enfants
j'ai rien fait tu leur fais collecter
des bouteilles et si jamais on ne te les
amène pas tu n'aimes pas tu le bagarre
avec les garçons ou alors tu les fais
strapper madame j'ai rien fait je vais
le montrer cet enfant en chef de la
police il te mettra en prison et une
aura même pas de caution pour te faire
libérer je vais m'occuper de toi tu vas
voir
j'étais expliqué dix fois d'arrêter
d'être drogués pour s'acheter ses doses
le jeune homme fait travailler les plus
petits enfants de la gare sous la menace
de représailles
c'est vrai qu'ils vous demandent de
reverser vos revenus moi il me demande
pas il ne peut pas mais il demande aux
autres aux autres il demande aux plus
jeunes parce qu'il peut les contrôler et
leur faire peur pour cette fois latta ne
fera pas arrêté le jeune homme
elle accepte de fermer les yeux
[Musique]
les enfants viennent nous voir parce
qu'ils ont confiance en nous alors on va
leur montrer qu'on a confiance on est
aussi mais je ne lui laisserait pas tout
le temps sa chance une fois deux fois ça
suffit
j'ai mes espions dans la gare la
prochaine fois s'il recommence
il ne pourra pas se cacher
[Musique]
18 heures le centre est fermé mais le
petit garçon n'a toujours pas récupéré
[Musique]
ce soir il ne pourra compter que sur la
solidarité de la bande recouvre le bien
sûr les autres
comme tous les soirs les enfants
passeront la nuit entre deux wagons en
attendant les trains du lendemain
quelques jours plus tard nous retrouvons
diane dans le quartier des tailleurs de
pierre finalement pour sa première
commande
elle s'est tournée vers l'une des
enseignes les plus réputés de la ville
[Musique]
lunettes
c'est une entreprise familiale tenue par
le père et son fils elle a trouvé chez
eux des pierres pour un premier bijou
qu'elle veut lancer sur le marché
français sa commande est très précise
cette taille de pierre exactement pour
faire ce modèle de base et donc je vais
demander des pierres bien précise non
calibrées la hauteur la largeur
circonférence sinon bah les pierres
elles vont pas rentrer elle doit on
choisir 50 et toutes les mesures et au
millimètre près elle n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur
[Musique]
si elle se trompe c'est une pierre
précieuse de perdus
[Musique]
diane hésite la commande ne correspond
pas exactement à ce qu'elle attendait
flat y en a qui sont un peuple atteint 8
le problème après c'est qu'elles sont
toutes différentes mais ça c'est très
beau je sais mais pourquoi tu mens n'a
pas apporté ce appareils soit possible
de trouver des biens exactement pareil
pas exactement pareil je sais mais en
france en général les deux titres savons
bien contient une ligne mais je peux
rien faire avec la nature différente
c'est l'heure des comptes le prix des
pierres est fixé en fonction du poids
chacun a sa balance et ça se joue au
centième de gramme près vous nous dites
41 son poids est plus léger que le fois
que j'ai vérifié
tant mieux ça mon avantage j'ai pourtant
combien 51,5 pas ce que je fais
diane grignote tout ce qu'elle peut son
budget est très serré
si tu peux faire un effort d'1 roupies
ou 2,18 mais c'est de la bonne qualité
oui c'est la bonne qualité mais il ya un
petit défaut la wii mais c'est la
meilleure qualité de black stars si tu
veux moins cher ce sera de la moins
bonne qualité pour l'esm a calculé diane
s'en tire plutôt bien pour 50 pierre
elle ne dépense que 108 euros la moitié
de son budget elle pense avoir fait une
bonne affaire en fait ce n'est pas tout
à fait le cas
dix jours plus tard elle vient récupérer
ses bagues
c'est un grossiste coréens installés à
jaïpur qui a certes il est pierre et il
n'a pas que des bonnes nouvelles
bon il faut que je vous dise il y a deux
pierres qui était trop petite de pierre
et on en a cassé deux autres donc ça
fait quatre bagues en moi c'est de ma
faute c'est parce que j'ai donc mal
sélectionnez la taille de la pierre et
en a deux qui sont cassé la pierre
devait déjà être fondu à l'intérieur et
on a on a certes ils sont en fait ça va
casser
et on peut savoir avant ça si on a 25
ans de métier derrière soi choquant fois
vers quatre bagues en moins un manque à
gagner de 16 euros mais l'apprenti
bijoutière est plutôt satisfaite le
reflet recherché dans l'amont stone le
reflet bleu irisé un coup d'essai
concluant pour la jeune bijoutière qui
espère maintenant convaincre les
grossistes français
elle se donne jusqu'à la fin de l'année
pour y parvenir et diane pourrait faire
des émules car jaïpur est devenu
incontournable aujourd'hui un tiers des
pierres précieuses coloré vendus dans le
monde transitent par la capitale du
rajasthan
[Musique]